en esta subasta ganadera también se hace
campaña política
bien el urabá antioqueño en el norte de
colombia ha sido víctima de todos los
males desde violencia hasta narcotráfico
pero también es una región próspera
bananera y ganadera y uno de los
bastiones del uribismo el movimiento
afín al ex presidente de derecha álvaro
uribe vélez hace 20 años rodrigo mejía
vive de comprar y vender vacas
a una actividad económica clave en una
región que nunca ha puesto en duda el
apoyo a su líder máximo
no hubiera cambio a la constitución en
colombia
volverá a presentar no solamente yo
votaría por él yo le aseguro que sería
nuevamente el presidente de colombia
pero las urnas no le hacen eco su
partido centro democrático se quedó sin
aspirante presidencial después de perder
21 escaños en el congreso en las pasadas
elecciones legislativas con lo que dejó
de ser la primera fuerza política
a pocos kilómetros en esta sede euro
venia del centro democrático ya no hay
un candidato propio para impulsar otro
aspirante de derechas se quedó con todos
los apoyos
que nosotros creemos que hay tiempos y
dinámicas en la política que
ya los jóvenes de hoy en día como te lo
decía requieren ideas frescas y nuevas
nosotros como muchos de los digamos de
los integrantes del partido también
veíamos que nos representaba la frescura
de de federico gutiérrez
muchachos
nació lotero no tiene ni vacas ni
bananos y no lidera campañas electorales
en su lugar fabrica ladrillos y aunque
quiere un cambio tampoco está listo para
votar por la izquierda primero porque
rompe
la empresa es la propiedad privada
todo lo que está diciendo la izquierda
en mentiras olvide que no va a hacer eso
y mañana termina siendo su voto de
confianza para el signo creo yo creo que
uribe ya
ya llegó a su cuarto de hora
por primera vez desde que dejó el poder
en 2010 un candidato presidencial
apadrinado abiertamente por álvaro uribe
no está la baraja de opciones
presidenciales dejando atrás más de 20
años de gloria para el político más
poderoso del país